wir haben keine angst ist
wissenschaftlich absolut ungeklärt ob
wir allein im weltall sind oder ob
lebewesen auf fremden planeten etwas
ganz normales sind zu ungewiss ist
welche bedingungen herrschen müssen
damit leben überhaupt entstehen kann
oder entsteht es gar nicht ich hab mir
mal ein paar gedanken zu den
geheimnissen des außerirdischen lebens
gemacht der pünktlich zum 20 14 herzlich
willkommen
wir haben wirklich nicht in blassesten
schimmer
ob er allein im weltall sind oder es
noch tausende oder vielleicht sogar
millionen andere bewohnte planeten oder
vielleicht sogar zivilisationen gibt die
nasa geht davon aus dafür in den
nächsten 20 jahren auf beweise für
außerirdisches leben treffen aber so
sicher ist das gar nicht denke ich
genauso könnte es auch sein dass die
bedingungen in unserem sonnensystem so
einzigartig sind das nur hier leben
entstehen konnte aber was braucht es für
das leben zunächst mal erdähnliche
planeten davon gibt es ja bei uns im
sonnensystem eine ganze reihe allerdings
fehlen ihnen alle zumindest nach
heutigem kenntnisstand die richtigen
bedingungen für leben
der merkur ist zb viel zu nah an der
sonne hat keine atmosphäre und entweder
ist es dort viel zu heiß oder viel zu
kalt die venus mit ihrer 42 atmosphäre
ist ein viel zu heikel freibad oder der
mars ist eine bühne gesteins müsste mit
einer fiesen atmosphäre allerdings
könnte es auf ihn erleben denn neben
haben und vielleicht finden sich heute
noch reste davon aber bis heute wurden
wie nicht aufgespürt er liegt zwar in
der habitablen zone also david leben
geben könnte aber ihm fehlt etwas
entscheidendes ein magnetfeld ohne darf
kann dort leben nicht vor strahlung
geschützt werden und es wird über kurz
oder lang zerstört ohne magnetfeld geht
es also schon mal gar nicht aber für das
rezept des lebens braucht es noch andere
bedingungen
so muss ein leben freundlicher planet
über nachbarn verfügen die akten und
andere objekte aus dem welt drauf
abfangen sie müssen durch ihre deutlich
höhere anziehungskraft alles was so
herumfliegt aus ihrer bahn auf sich
ziehen und dort und nicht auf dem
bevölkerten planeten einschlagen lassen
allein das sind bedingungen die die
auswahl deutlich einschränken auch in
dem jüngst entdeckten system capital one
oder trapp ist eins mit sogar wie die
erdähnliche gesteinsplaneten und drei
davon in der habitablen zone ist
fraglich ob diese bedingungen erfüllt
werden und es braucht noch eine menge
mehr nach heutigen wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen
so etwas wie die ursuppe nötig eine
spezielle zusammensetzung von chemischen
elementen die die entstehung der
grundbausteine des lebens überhaupt
ermöglicht natürlich wasser ohne wasser
kann nichts entstehen es bietet die
idealen bedingungen damit so kannten
sich überhaupt vermischen können und
miteinander chemische reagieren dann mit
hahn kohlenstoff ammoniak und so weiter
nur so und mit bestimmten bedingungen
kann leben entstehen
ich finde dass das schon eine menge
einschränkungen sind und sich die
chancen dass sich leben bilden kann ein
wenig anhören wie ein sechser im lotto
oder noch geringer allerdings gibt es so
viele galaxien und sternensysteme hat
auch darf nicht ganz unmöglich erscheint
oder die hypothese wird weltall sperma
stimmte facebook demnach fliegen aktiven
durch das universum und tragen die
grundelemente des lebens mikroben vom
planet zu planet und imitieren dort wo
die bedingungen stimmen leben leben
könnte dann auch ohne exakt die ganz
perfekten bedingungen auf einem planeten
entstehen dass mikroorganismen
theoretisch auf der fto iden überleben
können dafür bietet die jüngste
entdeckung der nasa astrobiologen einige
indizien
sie entdeckten jahr seit einigen zig
tausend jahren eingeschlossene lebende
mikroorganismen in einer höhle
wir hätten unter bestimmten bedingungen
auch auf einem aktiven überleben könnten
es gibt also immer noch für beide
annahmen zahlreiche gute gründe leben
ist der normalfall oder leben ist die
große ausnahme im universum den nächsten
jahren soll es dazu ständig neue
erkenntnisse geben wir halten euch
hierbei klicks um auf dem laufenden und
mittel nicht verpasst dort mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und klickt auch die glocke
an dann kriegt er immer nachrichten wenn
ein neues video online geht zb zum thema
außerirdisches leben ja und hier geht es
zu einem weiteren video zum eben thema
außerirdisches leben und ansonsten würde
ich mal sagen bis dann